what's up a blunt talk blender docks a
fantastic show created by Jonathan Ames
yes and the executive producer Seth
MacFarlane correct and who by the way is
a massive fan of yours
oh it's mutual yeah he's a he's
apparently and he just knows everything
about next generation yeah I think he
knows the names of the episodes and it
was his it was his idea that I should
come and be in American Dad which is now
in its 11th season yeah but one night we
were in a rather well-known restaurant
in Beverly Hills myself and Jonathan
Frakes and brent Spiner and michael dorn
and levar burton having dinner together
Seth came in and this this is a man
who's pretty confident yes I mean he's
hosted the Academy Awards he sings with
symphony orchestras he's written smash
hit shows and he was clearly what
unsettled by encountering all of a city
entire cast of his I was sitting
together
I mean he had this stupid grin on it
[Laughter]
he's he's he said could he join us so he
sat at our table but you know set for
fallen witty guy funny yeah no wit no
jokes no no just staring around them hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography